wait you ready okay welcome back to
another episode of your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
are we over the singer - yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and the singer mike is always here if
you want to go to it if you want to get
on the singer might get on it you know
so much as you need to make sure okay
here are you saying again to turn you
way up okay look you see me I'm doing
all this by myself
I got you know it's like when people
listening like oh do I sound funny but
it's just like it's gonna sound fine
there this is just how it sounds when
it's coming in like this but we all good
ladies and gentlemen I want to welcome
to the podcast the very funny my good
friend I've known for many many years
the hilarious miss Shantae Wayans yeah
thanks for coming out freakin love you
bro I'm glad you came on you know it's
like I was saying to you earlier it's
like you know let's say you wanted to
Jackson's to come on you know Michael's
not available Jan is busy look nobody
can file a toy yet Randy's gone I
couldn't find Jemaine I can't even get
above Jermaine or Tito you like you like
Lawndale Jackson put you at 3t in the
Wayans family you like what 3t number
one the last thing before he passed away
unfortunately Pete
MJ but he had a
for land party he didn't show up for a
while and I bought a chick there to try
to you know try to smooth so I was like
you want to go get tickets to go see
Michael Jackson right so we go to this
event and he didn't show up for three
hours right right and so third hour I'm
like screw this we start walking out and
I just saw the umbrella this is it I I
don't think people understand the power
like do you have a favorite person that
you okay this is okay this is I'm so
glad we talked away starting with this
cuz I got so many Michael Jackson
stories okay so my age I'm all about
Michael Jackson okay so in 1984 I went
to the Victory Tour at Dodger Stadium
and this is I'm talking about this is
the height of his power okay he was like
the most famous anybody could possibly
ever be in the history you know and so I
saw that and then I just was a Michael
Jackson fan you know forever
I remember watching Motown 25 live that
night and then the next day I came to
school and everybody was trying to
moonwalk you know it was like that I saw
that so but okay so I got just crazy
first of all before we even go on you
know like I said this is Shante Wayans
okay and she just had a great she was on
the Netflix that show produced by
Tiffany Haddish they ready it was you
Ida Rodriguez Tracy Ashley and so it's
on Netflix streaming right now so make
sure you go watch it this is
legitimately one of the funniest people
I know the way her mind works and we go
get into all this - I mean you know just
being black being lesbian being away ins
[Laughter]
I call Keenan he was
I couldn't even get Damon jr. you can't
even get his kids my podcast people cuz
you gotta get away and then and then you
call me and you can't even pronounce my
name I know I called it is Shawntel
there Jackson crazy story I have so okay
so now he's my remember that 30 year
anniversary concert he was gonna have in
New York
okay so 30 year anniversary concert in
New York and my buddy of mine Jeff he
knew this dude named Kevin okay and
Kevin he told us that he was Michael
Jackson's musical director okay now he's
a I just gotta say this about him he is
a what do you call it a not a habitual
liar but like one of those like that's
like a disease no okay so he got now
what happens is though he has a little
bit of truth so he actually worked with
Michael Jackson and he at a time okay
and then he was like on American Idol
and in the band okay you can eat you
could even see him on TV okay you could
see him Michael don't let anybody okay
listen you think we know that there's a
little bit of truth at the time okay so
he tells us he gonna get us tickets to
the 30 year anniversary
he looks um listen I'm Michael's musical
director and we're gonna get you tickets
to Michael's 30 year anniversary party
okay yes Jeff and I my buddy Jeff and I
he we we get tickets to New York I hit
up my college roommate who lives in New
York and I'm like bro can we stay with
you it's just one night he's like dude
and then he goes through some changes
cuz he don't have a night good enough
couch he's one of these dudes is like I
can have people at my place without
having a good cat so he goes and buys a
couch okay now wait wait is he going to
the concert that's so then alright it's
a week is two weeks before the concert
we got the plane tickets and everything
and I say to Jeff I go
yo man what you got the tickets because
I'm thinking they special - they like
gold-plated with like you know it's like
Michael xxx anniversary he's like you
know what actually I don't have a ticket
[ __ ] let me hit up Kevin he hits up
Kevin Kevin's like yo I don't got two
tickets yet but don't worry just go to
New York
okay so about a two days before it's
time to leave the dudes wife calls Jeff
and she says listen I'm so sorry but
he's been lying this whole time and cuz
turns out he lies about everything like
he he ain't paying the rent ain't paying
their kids bills at the school they go
to he's just one of these dudes that
just lies so but let me tell you -
Shante wait no no I'm doing this because
I'm going women will have your back to
the end of the day if you ruin them
right yeah and the moment the more like
they wait they pay attention to every
[ __ ] thing and the moment you do some
bad something that pissed them off you
can lower the chair by the way alright I
don't know I feel like you like on the
side you can lower it a little bit there
you go
this is worse I feel like you're trying
to set something up for me right now you
can like your legs can be on the ground
I like I lowered my soul I like swinging
my leg okay lift yourself back up you
know so sorry
the whole thing you just looked
uncomfortable you look like you was like
okay my legs don't touch the ground I
don't feel like I'm on steady now I'm
gonna go tell ya business when I leave
you just piss me off but that's why I
stopped you I was just like it's so
funny how women they literally absorb
everything you're saying until the
moment they need it so I thought that
was really funny that she they call she
called you yes she called us to tell us
like but here's the thing that's really
troubles some about the whole thing this
do said go to new
you work you got your tickets already
yeah so he bought a new couch my other
for my mother but my egg my roommate got
a new couch we got tickets to New York
and he said just go to New York like
people that like habitual liars you
don't I mean they like that would have
kept the lie going so then but he was
gonna have us at will-call talking about
yeah um you know Michael Jackson's
musical director said okay it should be
under Griffin we would have been like oh
no okay Kevin
he didn't okay um this time you weren't
like at a certain point you had career
no okay so you just wasn't like now you
know how it feels to be a unknown way
and walking up the comedy clubs like yo
I'm Shante but I'm just saying you know
I want you to be comfortable I'm very
comfortable even gonna mention it okay
um but the thing is like he like I say
he gonna have us in New York you know
that I would have had my one glove on
you know what I mean cuz I'm you know I
mean I would have moonwalk thriller
Jackie I want to walk up the wheel call
like this and I would you don't think I
would have caused a scene like no no go
get the music so I just felt like it was
just but anyways we went through all
that because I loved Mike we loved
Michael Jackson like there's just no not
loving Michael Jackson at that time no
we didn't we didn't go to New York
no because Michael Jackson yeah but we
didn't go because we thought to dude was
gonna no no because the wife told us it
was already bad the ticket I know but we
didn't but we didn't have the ticket to
the concert but if you would have got
there and saw the umbrella walking in
the building that's all you need it yeah
I you know what no but I just I'm sure
he ain't walking through the front door
it's not 1962 you know I mean you got
lucky that time you're gonna mean he
would have been like an underground limo
we wouldn't have even seen him
damn but anyways but anyways thank you
know for sure
I love talking about Michael Jackson
there so like so what do you think about
the allegations and all that stuff then
and everything that's happened since
what about your thoughts on I think it's
really hard to be to love somebody who
spread so much love and not know what
they've been through in life oh you
almost sound like you're giving him an
excuse Kelly I was a I was a deejaying
at this party recently and I played you
know rock with you and all this stuff
and you know black women up in there and
they like crazy like I'm so sorry but
she literally did one of these as soon
as I was like I'm so sorry it's so crazy
how people I don't know I've been on a
deep dive about this I've had many
discussions about this and I'm not even
trying to like like I want to say this
right now I am NOT defending Michael
Jackson I don't know here nor there
about what really happened and there's
many people that are like where there's
smoke there's fire
right but my thing is this that whole in
situation happened to pre social media
right okay so now no no no my point
about it is is like oh there are so many
people that have been researching this
now I'm talking about lawyers legit
journalists have been investigating and
because they're captivated by Michael
Jackson and the whole story for 25 years
and now they have a voice and a place to
put their stuff if you start googling
Michael Jackson innocent or Michael
anything you
we'll be shocked at all cuz first of all
all the court records are available like
it says so you can investigate so many
things on your own like that documentary
that just came out is it is it's a it's
a travesty because the first of all the
guy's dead he can't defend himself and
they didn't did they didn't talk to
anybody but when you start looking up
even things about them you'll go down a
rabbit hole and be like I'm not a huge
documentary guy
I think documentaries are important but
they should be taken with a grain of
salt see to me documentaries is somebody
trying to push their agenda and when you
put the word documentary on it the
people the average consumer sees that
and goes well this must be true right
this has to be true because it's a
documentary we'll come to find out to
know this is just somebody pushing their
own narrative and you have to like after
you get this information you have to go
okay let me find out what else is going
on so that's what I thought about that
particular documentary and it's just
amazing when you just start looking I
went down like a three-hour rabbit hole
I'll send you some links he's like what
but but but here's the deal too it's
also my biggest thing and I agree with
you like I don't know what was true or
not and I've been in situations so I get
how painful yeah it can be however I
think as parents there's no way in hell
I and I've even really watched a whole
documentary but just seeing the trailer
and the parents talking about going to
Neverland and getting on these rides and
allowing their young child to be with
this guy well you know but see this is
the thing too is like if it's just on
the surface if it was that and I don't
think it was that I just think that
that's what we've all put in together
over the years and that's what we've
heard no no no it's actually way more
than that it's not as simple as like
saying like he came over and he slept in
my bed it's just like so much more than
that when you start to really dive into
like what from the people's testimony
themselves and what people are saying
about how it really happened you know
what I mean I mean was the dude weird
yes you know him Michael Jackson we are
yes did he have a weird upbringing yes
that he did was he like a regular person
he was too rich to be a regular person
funny though I heard he was
super regular at home like he would talk
to people be like yo where the [ __ ]
at but he got a deep voice and every Oh
like he would not gonna it's not gonna
work but I'm saying at home I heard he
actually has a deep voice we'll see this
is what I'm saying these are all the
kind of things that we don't know the
ins and outs so yeah you should I don't
know but then like there are Kelly was
that when when are Kelly you busted out
well how did you feel about that what
was your initial thoughts this is such a
bad topic to talk about because I look
at both I look at both sides and again I
experienced thing in my life and I think
what happens is here's the here's the
deal I think that people they don't try
to fix the system they don't try to fix
what's happening so what happens is out
of the all those girls that he did that
too
right I I can almost promise that some
of them wind up doing something hurtful
to somebody else
and so as they're the victims right now
they wind up becoming the monsters well
no that's what he is saying happened to
him your sister your sister messes with
you you blow up like right after that
like there you got all these yes men
it's almost it's almost more I don't
want to say more messed up but the
people that was protecting him
yeah like oh they say that they one guy
in that documentary he was like he was
ashamed he was like yeah I I doctored
the documents or whatever I was like
damn
can't be that ashamed that's that's
money talking but but I'm I think it's
very I'm not saying that our Kelly is
right and all this stuff but then you
got a look at the rest of the world
because the rest of world after he did
that he did a hub party in Chicago and
these chicks showed up and was like
kidnap me are Kelly I know but that's
that but but that doesn't okay I hear
what you're saying and that's just a I
think this is a comment on the state of
you know how
people are as humans and how
psychologically things affect people
because it's just like serial killers
have groupies but it don't mean that
because they have groupies it's okay to
be a serial and I know you're not saying
that but I'm saying I just want to make
it clear they're like yeah yeah and I
don't think that you're saying that
you're condoning his actions but the
thing is you know he was in a position
of look look if you if you got money and
you're walking around the ghetto you're
in a position of power if you like you
know when an ice cream truck pull up and
you like ice cream like Nino brown
someone turkeys today today you know I
mean he's throwing turkeys to the poor
people because it's a you and you
becoming a per so if you now are in that
position of authority of power of like
influence you know your actions are
scrutinized Moorhead no matter what this
other person willingly does like
quote/unquote willingly it's like you
know you're not supposed to do that no
you know I mean I I think I think more
so as a psychological thing and I think
yeah it's it's this is the again this is
one of the worst topics to talk about
because I'm not trying to defend him at
all no I got ideologically if you're not
fixing the mental then you just have a
person who screwed up and they had no
but again your sister your sister
smashed you and I think his dad or uncle
or somebody like that it was some kind
of horrible story imagine like who's the
closest person to you in your life well
look I understand it where I know we're
talking about like it's like you know
you got to go to what's the origin and
then in stacked the sins of the father
trickle down to everybody else and yes
but like there are a lot of people that
even have gone through that that didn't
go out and do necessarily what he did if
what the he did is true you know but you
know it's just I just think that the we
don't have to talk about this anymore
but to me it's like what was crazy about
it is that we are actually culpable in
this because a
you had a song age ain't nothing but a
number like what I'm saying is like it
was out there like when they when that
documentary was going on and they were
talking about him going to court and
then getting married and all this a week
I thought oh [ __ ] we already knew she
was underage we already knew that they
were in a relationship
oh damn but but anyways I don't think
what he did was right
here's that topic and it's gone it's
gone okay
Netflix special it's out now now
streaming they ready is they ready I
love Tiffany she I've had her on the
podcast and good for her for trying to
reach down reach across reach up and
just like get everybody together you
know what I mean
so that's good as she's doing that and
but like how is it been for you like you
know I'm starting to realize something
it's like as a male comic we go we do we
have a catch all women be whatever it is
right but then what I realize is like
the the the the spectrum of like the
different types of women is so vast it's
it's actually probably why y'all don't
always get along because it's like not
they're not even the same creatures at
certain age ranges I teach chicks on the
view you know these old [ __ ] like
look ya'll oh you're like a young girl
or do some stuff and they up there like
to myself oh wow
you don't remember what it was like to
be young beautiful and like you know
it's amazing right so I just realized so
they know here you are in this little
like what a like weird spectrum to be in
you know black woman in the United
States lesbian comedian not you know
it's like how is how is that Road been
for you go very hard and I think I think
I'm naturally just like a rebellious
person but you know I talk about my I
had an agent who was super flamboyant
and even him you know
one meter like he wanted me to be this
like fabulous type of chick you know the
mean and and I think that on I mean
let's face it like you know a lot of
dudes a lot of dudes that like you know
take girls on tour sometimes they're the
attracted to them or they you know like
might want to smash it some type of way
or they can be super cool I'm not saying
us everybody but we are attracted to we
okay I just wanted to come in on that
way you're saying is like yeah it's like
it's nice to be around people you're
attracted to yeah
regardless if you trying to you know
this is the reason why we like pretty
waitresses and we like to know you know
handsome models selling us underwear
it's like so I get it so go on and I do
the same thing like I just started
realizing that if I hold a conversation
with somebody if I'm I might be
attracted to you if I can actually sit
there more than five minutes what sucks
and if I'm not attracted to you I want
to smoke a cigarette I'm like a
fustrated I need to get out of here and
I go crazy my anxiety kicks in
but I do understand it I think I think
like trying to go on tour with dudes at
times it was more about like I don't
know if they thought I was gonna try to
get they chicks
oh hi or they was like man I can't smash
and you competition right right right
type of stuff which is you know me like
from I'm trying to ally you for you well
I will say it sometimes I said you walk
in and I'm like God do this to me push
me out the way and walk up to you so
it's like you know I mean there's a lot
of benefits but I just think it's been
harder not only because of that but
mostly because like the way I dress the
way you know there's there's nothing
over here that's going like I want to be
around that at time I get what you're
saying so it's like I was talking about
this the other day with someone about
like I was like how about it seems that
femininity is like we're scared of it in
the comedy business too like we're like
like on stage like we were scared of
like for femininity to be just
out there right you know like that's why
you most good lot of female comics they
dressed down I got ponytails they're
wearing jeans I got a little jackets on
to keep the titties in check and you
know you're not you naturally doing that
anyway you know I mean you got a
starting to swag about you you know me
but it's like but then masculinity it's
not like that at all it's like you know
these these handsome you know a-type
personality comics they out there being
as masculine as possible and that has a
different effect on the crowd you know I
so like the women in the crowd alike I
think and dude
but then reversed it it's like so we
don't have this same it's weird that we
can't have the same reaction to a female
comic I think there's very the comedy
that I like when I like to watch like I
can watch you I could watch this this
certain comics that I can watch and and
I hate watching comics but there's
certain people I can watch because y'all
literally inspire me to go home and
write more because I'm like I don't even
know how you made that topic like the
funny so I I watch it and I go home and
I'm like okay now I can go on to this
rant of something that I didn't expect
to do I say that to say like I think
there's a lot of women who you know you
do hear about sex a lot you do hear
about certain things and one of the
things I love about comedy is like who
are you what's your truth like if you're
a freaking Muslim and you know you wear
a hijab do you want to take that off
sometimes like what's that world okay
you know I'm saying like do you say -
are you saying that you think that the
female comics in your experience aren't
delving into like who they really are
some of them there's very few of them
that I look you know I love yamaneika
Jeannie a Sheree like you know Tiffany
that there's only certain people that
could really bring out something a
little different not know I wanna say
they can bring out something different
I just think it's a comfortable topic to
talk about and a lot of girls do talk
about dick at times they do not and I'm
talking about
this stuff that I've seen I'm not true
I'm not like dissing
female comics cuz there's some funny
female comics ok so then of those funny
female comics I'm saying who were like
do we need to get you some new socks if
you have you saw my feet right now you
blame we may give you some new feet cut
to a picture of your feet right here no
but I'm saying ok so what about the ones
that are like they're saying hey you
know I got a nice body I'm beautiful I'm
up here and I am trying to show my truth
but I can't get past with the crowd the
fact that you know I look this way or
they they're they're uncomfortable with
you know the women are uncomfortable
because they're like look at their man
is looking at them or or whatever the
thing might be but but again what's your
world cuz it's not you just being pretty
it's not you you know I'm saying what
are what are the things that you go
through would being pretty I know but
sometimes you can't give sometimes it's
like an elephant in a room like if you
know if you you know it's like if her
okay here's I was gonna here's a non
sexist way to talk about this I remember
there was this dude dis comic I forgot
his name but he had a thing with his
hand like his hand was like he had like
a birth defect where his hand was like
you're like it just was crazy okay but
he would go up on stage you know holding
the mic and it's like you gotta give me
one joke about this [ __ ] hand or the
whole time I'm gonna be like okay did
you do you burn it like just somebody
run it over I mean it's like so all I'm
saying is like sometimes that could be
the elephant in the room you got big-ass
titties are you just like so pretty that
people are like you know they were just
like it's like what do you think it's
necessary to disarm the crowd with
whatever your thing is I think it's
already hard for us naturally I think if
you're not famous women comedians that's
if you if if people don't know you you
already got to put that work in you know
Sam but when you walk up and you're like
I remember this comic is she was gonna
say [ __ ] like I'm
no I'm fine and you know and then and
she'll go into her being pretty and then
she'll turn around and show her butt and
stuff like that but it was theirs I'd
rather watch somebody bomb onstage with
material look at what the stuff that
makes like like that that was good they
just wasn't like I get you I get you and
again this is what I'm saying about how
women are different you just have a
different perspective like your struggle
going on stage and trying to you know do
what you've been doing is it's been a
different experience than say some like
you know super feminine you know girl
that's up there like whatever you know I
mean but there's just some out there
just you know I could just I could just
tell I could feel the struggles what I'm
saying
oh I can feel the struggle sometimes of
like the crowd is like you know feeling
a certain way so but it but that's just
what we naturally have been I mean it's
it's just it's that system again you
know I'm saying like this is our natural
belief or you know how we how we see
things in life and I think there's some
super funny woman out there and I think
that shows I think we're growing I think
we're getting to a place and the ones
that are really good they're gonna stand
out I mean I'm taking a sketch class
right now so you know you try to write
stuff out I wrote something out the
other day and thought it was brilliant
and you know when you hear people read
your [ __ ] you like sometimes okay you
know I remember Damon jr. Daniel jr. had
this sketch show he was doing and I went
to do like a sketch on it like for them
to Vinnie no no wasn't the Underground a
lot of it this one didn't come out but I
went and like it was so bad like it was
this [ __ ] was terrible okay and I you
know I knew it was really bad this
camera girl the girl the camera woman
she's like you know we she's filming us
and then like you know we're doing our
supposedly funny [ __ ] and it's it at the
end she was cut you know she was just
looking like this and I said to her I
was like nothing from you she was like
you know you if you see a crew it's like
at a calm
club I always ask the waitresses yeah
from on a road I asked the waitresses
and the staff whatever you know I said
hey yeah you enjoying the show she's
like oh you're so funny I know they mean
it cuz they gotta watch all six shows
they see comedy every week and they got
a deal with whatever they had to see the
same material over but if they're
telling me like oh I really enjoy your
you know that is real so you know well I
must say this
I remember what sketch show that was and
I was writing on that too but the
problem was we had it was a lot of
problems don't tell me what just no no
no I'm gonna tell you why the editing
became a huge problem it's not even just
a joke with the editor they wind up
finding the people who hired them loved
him so much
but in every sketch he edited he will
put these sound effects in that make
knows it sounds like a corny white guy
Oh bro no is Italian dude like and he
just loved mafia movies and so you heard
a lot of like effects like that well but
it's hard so you wanna you do you want
to be in front of the camera more I you
know I look like my uncle Kenan I like
how you know he was able to write and
then write himself in it yeah by the way
you know we made reference to it but you
Shantae is a Jackson yes in the Wayans
family Kenan Damon you know the the
white chicks apparently they are they
all crazy you know I mean who you think
the funniest it's so hard to say you you
gotta be I'm gonna just say this
everybody family you got you got a
favorite [ __ ] you got a favorite
the funny you have to hear me out
because they're all different
here we go
so Shawn was the person who helped me
start writing my comedy right and I know
you know people say what they say but
Shawn is like ridiculously brilliant so
he would listen it would be like I
[ __ ] hate you it would be like okay
so she bro you know listen if you said
something right this is how I go you say
something to start a joke right and then
this person is gonna elevate that
and there's Shawn impersonates Shawn
knows I do a lot of impersonations then
that's gonna take it to Damon and then
Keenan just comes out the woodwork with
like weird where did that come from but
you got Damon jr. you got Craig so what
I'm saying is everybody elevates their I
hate you you're not gonna have me talk
about my friend oh I love them all I
didn't ask you who you love the most I
said who do you think write funny
I probably I probably have the most fun
with Damon and Shawn okay to me Damon's
the funniest like it's not even close
but he just but we all know that yeah
but because it's just different levels
but they don't put that out in the front
I can go to Keenan sounds like part of
me is pissed because when me doing this
special every time I go out to him he's
like what you doing and I'll start doing
a joke and he blank what about this and
he'll act it out he's so Mellie man
would you think yeah yeah and then I
just be like where the hell have you
been my entire career well I mean it's
like it didn't mean it is what it is you
want to do it on your own anyway you
know what I mean that's not remember
when David jr. started doing comedy his
ass was like Count green yeah he would
come out as somebody new because he but
then it's so dumb cuz he looked just
like his dad I know but they look really
cool that people still knew I look like
them and nobody cared dude you don't see
let me see
hey Shawn you look away Marlon let me
just show you a picture just see you see
the nose I don't see it
I haven't put it up we're gonna put them
up right here we go boy lay your picture
I don't know I just
but you did to me is Damon Damon senior
Damon's dark and that's why he's so
bright he did no I just I also just like
how he performs things Damon so down you
know what he's just you know he performs
things and then like Marlon I think I
like his commitment oh yeah like he'll
do something and he'll stay on a
character for like like like an extended
period of time and then people don't
necessarily laugh but they're gonna be
like this wow that was amazing we did a
dance flick yeah his scene alone which
was all no have you seen dance flick
there was there was a scene where he was
playing his character I was like ma flap
he was like this acting coach and it
took us the entire day shoot his scene
and it was only supposed to be like hour
and a half to our topic yeah he just he
just dynamic that way but him and
cambree mommy at each other like when
they they commit that's right that's I
haven't even seen her come out there
Chad they're doing it someplace she
doing it she gotta you know I thought
you gonna be like yes you got a
chick-fil-a and you see that she got to
7-eleven okay nothing wrong dynamic
comedy family obviously yeah and it's
still going you know what I mean that
that's that's what's great about it not
to just talk about them just to focus
back on you I mean was there pressure is
there pressure do you still feel
pressure today like being like your
wanes
you know it's weird seeing seeing a
special drop I think I think event like
people they feel what I'm doing because
I don't I don't think I for
me I didn't really try to go the normal
way you know I wanted to like I remember
people telling me to change my jokes and
you don't have to talk about so much LBT
stuff and blah blah and I'm like no you
don't understand like if anything I want
to get all this [ __ ] out in this special
and then I can go into whatever whatever
it is but I want to do this because I
want to be one of the first comedians
that tackles on these jokes the way I've
been trying to do it uh-huh you know me
but that's that's like and to be honest
I've actually try to go on stage with
like my cleavage out and and do stuff
and and as I'm going stage trying to
tell my jokes none of their floppy it's
just it's not the same image as what I'm
talking about didn't jump by three dudes
looking like I do so do you think that
do you think that the image and the
words are important relationship yeah
why you can't talk about being a nerd
and look like cool dude yeah yeah it
just because people were sitting people
there's a delay you know I'm saying so
like I remember going on stage at one
point in my career and I would be like
why are people laughing like I'm going
into my family stuff and I'm trying to
do this and then I realized I'm walking
on stage with big breasts and I look
like a dude and one of my quickest jokes
that wind up working well for me was
y'all looking at me confused like who
was this dude with titties on the stage
right and that opens up okay that's what
I was saying earlier though that's what
I'm talking about
like you can't go onstage the way you
are it's like that's like the weird hand
people are like even though they know
even though they know for some reason
that people need you to say yeah I get
it I'm lesbian or you know yeah I look
like a dude with a you know yeah okay
let's get past that so I could talk
about this I mean you'd I mean that's
what I was saying earlier so let me ask
you a question because now Eddie
Murphy's coming out mm-hmm do you think
he has to talk about what he stopped
doing his career
I let me tell you my best advice for
Eddie Murphy honestly and he's the
reason why I'm doing comedy today like
there's no other reason I loved Eddie
Murphy um he he should get roasted
and then had that talk you don't think
he should say it no no I think they he
himself I think that he should be there
should be a Comedy Central Roast or
Netflix role so you can go buckwild and
he should allow like say whatever you
want it would it would catapult him back
into the public art you know I mean like
cuz then he would get his chance but you
don't think people want to well he's
gonna he's gonna go up last right yeah
because he's getting roasted he's doing
okay he gets to go up last and like
respond to all these things we talked
about everybody then have his moment and
that'll just then he could be more clear
I think it'll be all it'll be all good
to see all the I know what I mean I'm
what I'm saying there was like I just
feel like I just feel like he's been so
famous and I don't think he's a real
person anymore
well he's lived in he just he goes to
coffee bean and he just stays at his
house with all his kids and grandkids
well now but before he you know he was
always seen at that one coffee bean they
keep started calling it Eddie Murphy
coffee bean you know he just would be
there but like I just think that I
thought I always thought that he just
has such a profound respect for stand-up
comedy that's why he stopped doing it
cuz it's like what am I gonna talk about
you know I'm so rich I'm so famous I'm
like you know what can i what am i i
think he just has a respect for it that
he's like afraid to go out and do it but
ever since he was saying you know on
that Seinfeld thing he was like he's
gonna do it I would love to [ __ ] see
that I think he's gonna be brilliant but
I don't know if he's gonna be brilliant
I think it's gonna take some time cuz I
don't necessarily think that he was ever
brilliant like delirious doesn't
necessarily stand up watching today you
go if you watch rod he was calling back
from delirious that's how you know you
didn't care it was still Ross my
favorite [ __ ] I used to be able to I
used to be able to do raw from beginning
to end
even the inflections yeah
I know why like people are like but he
just you know I don't know but I think
you got I I think that's the the biggest
thing in there that's when he stopped
it is when that time happened what do
you mean as when he got caught with the
transversal no he didn't stop doing
comedy then he was he'd already stopped
doing County before that how long I
think I was talking about coming back
out well maybe but I think that he
stopped doing comedy I don't think he I
think like the last time he did a tour
was probably around raw and then that
was it that was it that was it he wasn't
out there doing comedy anymore yeah and
all that stuff was going on while he was
like you know you know golden child
Beverly Hills Cop 3 and all these other
[ __ ] movies that he was doing I
always feel like I wanna my dream mister
like he comes to the comedy store and
I'm on stage and I have to bring him on
stage that's just gonna be my I just
want that to happen you know I want to
be like oh come on you know I want to be
like come to the stage you know it's
like Beverly Hills Cop you know but then
like progressively be like it gets
worried like oh then there was Pluto
Nash where he was like the Guru guy I
was like he does a bad I liked I
actually really like Norbit though nor
the right Norbit was really you all
right don't let sketch show it was dark
you do like dark things but that you
like you gravitate towards the darkness
your dark sometimes no you're a frickin
dark well I find like you know I just
find my perspective sometimes it's like
it leans on to like like you know this
is going on you know I mean like you
know those dudes like if I heard you say
I love you mm-hmm then I would believe
it oh you're like cuz you just don't
you're not that guy that's out that's
how dark you are
well I guess that's the compliment I
guess I don't know I mean I just I'm
trying to think Oh
during I know this happens every we
think if Shawn was on the phone would
ring I don't know I I thought you know
what I've had my stepfather who's white
you know I haven't necessarily been
closer to him but I always appreciated
that he loved my mom and he would say
helping take care of her so I didn't
have to worry about it as much but I'll
never forget the moment him and I bonded
for the first time ever is we sitting on
the couch you know it's one of those
things where we don't really like what
like first is my mom was trying to get
us to like each other so she sent us to
we went to the symphony him and I at the
Hollywood Bowl like we sitting there
he's falling asleep I'm like trying not
to fall asleep and then it was like that
was one moment we looked at each other
like both sleeping and we started
laughing and I was like we thinking to
ourselves we don't want to be here right
I should just be like that's just bounce
let's go get dinner and tell her we
enjoyed it you know so that was a that
was one bonding moment but the best
bonding moment ever is were sitting on
the couch cable comes on white chicks
comes on right and then we look here and
it was like one of these kind of things
are cracking up like that legit is one
of the funniest [ __ ] movies just
stupid is so stupid
it's so stupid because the reason why
that movie is so dumb is because you
have to in your mind go okay I have to
believe that people think they look like
white women and once you get past that
block
you're just you're on board right like
Terry Crews
but you know it's funny like I like you
don't like it I can tell no no I did
like I like I like the white I like to
like okay so John five-way movies go oh
man I'm gonna get you sucker don't be a
minute okay okay little man little man
was funny to me because of malt like his
facial expressions so I asked him in
person I'm like could you do he's just
he's committed okay our lists are
completely different like you I don't
even get you
first of all movie is number one the
first one is like that statement better
than that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
hilarious okay I'm just talking about
always all together
Dirty Shame okay Keeney was thinking it
was just trying to put two bad chicks in
a movie yeah yeah yeah I love major
Payne yeah major Payne is that I say
that's how I st. white chicks
I think his scary movie white chicks
major Payne and then the one with Damon
in and in Adam Sandler oh I forgot the
name of that one yeah they were yeah
they were that one and I also liked the
one with Bruce Willis no I'm not Adam
Sandler and Damon Wayans were in a movie
together where he was a cop and they
were partners but it turns out that he
was Damon was like undercover and then
he and then and and then like put the
other one in jail cuz he didn't know
that they were like partners
oh my god it's you know what it's right
here on this remember going to that
premiere and I we might not have been
brave like you're not that what are you
talk about you couldn't even say
um I'm gonna get you sucker no I first I
know but I wasn't a huge fan of that one
you didn't like I'm gonna get you sucker
okay I'm going to Damon Wayans IMDB okay
you didn't like I don't it was okay
alright um my wife and kids
alright made your pain Mo Money oh okay
guys lethal weapon was to me like
Lewthwaite
it's coming there's a living color
bulletproof [ __ ] bulletproof you
must love bamboozle - not a lie babbles
about girls easy I don't even see there
it is here yeah we'll see you have to
watch those like a family newsletter
make sure watch make sure y'all watch
bamboozled that's uh we won't hear it
it's on the computer I think um one of
the funniest things about the earth
girls are easy though is Jim Carrey
Davis spoke they were aliens right no
Jim Carrey would learn the thing they
were saying uh-huh and no one he messed
up and be mad and literally they could
have been like and he was like yeah he
was like oh man he would get mad at
saying it wrong was like bro nobody
understands any of this anyway uh yeah
they had like I remember they live in
color days and
all that premieres and beer to get out
of school and stuff like that really
yeah it was like are they the first
family of comedy you think like is there
another family of comedy people that is
like more prolific than if we combine
all the careers you talk about homeboys
and on his face no wasn't homeboys in
outer space
what was that dumb the Wayans brothers
yeah you know when those two like how
many times are they gonna kiss on that
show I'm grandma I used to make us do
that you know my funny my here's a funny
story for you so you know Vinnie Oshana
yeah you know so it was like so Vinnie
was like middle infer it was Vinnie and
Damon jr. was but but drinian Damon you
were going to roll with it the dad so
Damon jr. has something to do so I
filled in and I'll never forget this
Damon at the time he was saying to me he
was like talking about like hanging and
my kids they don't call me like he was
like upset about like he was having
issues with his you know family issues
but if it was turns out love I gotta
bring you over he got that taken care of
now he's golden right you know he was
like but no but he was saying that's why
he's like talking about so that I
remember at the end of the at the end in
a week he was like yeah you know what
I'm I have you replaced Damon
permanently you know he was making a
joke then I said to him that's why your
kids don't wanna clean ever worked with
him again
Damon could take jokes a little bit oh
he's a [ __ ] yeah I've been at
the club I was and he walked up to me I
was like hey what's up man he was like
when you going on come on bump you
[Laughter]
they're all weird man they all like you
know they all got their little quirks
you know they've been a game for a
minute yeah they had I think I mean my
face we've had some amazing times
especially early on an acre
oh really think like I remember
graduating from New Jersey high school
and and I remember I had a friend I had
a best friend he was in 11th grade and I
was graduating so I told him he can come
over but we had this house but it was
super small the living room was like you
know mm-hm this big and stuff like that
but we had upstairs and that was that
big so not a lot of people can come into
our house my best friend comes over and
literally he lived around a corner for
me I swear it's like a movie he came
over with like half of his family his
mother's in a wheelchair and he you just
see him coming down the middle of the
street with like his whole crew and I'm
like bro like what are you doing so they
come in the house they want a picture
this how funny my family is my name is
Roy yeah yeah so so they go okay you
want a picture no problem so he puts all
of them like they sit on the couch my
uncles and my cam like they stand above
them so whoever's taking a picture only
takes a picture of their shoulders they
didn't know that they didn't get the
picture we do and we took like ten of
them it was just them like doing Oh your
daughter y'all [ __ ] up oh we're bad
yeah you guys are really [ __ ] up well
that's good I mean I just feel like but
I just want to know like what's next for
you like go like like I say what do you
see yourself doing like what do you what
do you want to do what do you want to be
remembered for like what's you know you
did this special I'm sure you wanted you
actually your own special because it was
like a collaborative like your there's
like five ladies on the show six six
ladies on the show five and a half right
counting yeah right there's one of them
was kind of big so let's just call this
a kidding I'm not gonna feed into that
this is a powerful year for us okay no
no I think
you know what's so funny right now is
like if we weren't recorded I would be
saying we would just be saying that we
just it's just I know but it's like you
know we got I just think it's fine to
have to be more thoughtful about
people's feelings and stuff I think
that's what the timing you don't think
so I think just you don't care about
people's feelings I do but it let me get
to a point in my career where I cannot
care as much do you think that that you
think that that's still the do you think
that should be the goal do you think
that don't you think that being
thoughtful I personally believe that
like let's say I still want to be if I
still want to have a misogynistic joke
then I feel like a greater challenge is
to be able to say it thoughtfully and
still get that point across
I'll give you an example of something
cuz like I have jokes about I had this I
had this experience where this Amazon
delivery person was handicapped you know
and you know exactly it's a nightmare
like you know what I'm saying
like are you kidding me you know and the
dude was like I'm okay so I talked about
it on stage but I talked about it in a
way that it's like I'm not [ __ ] on
handicapped people I'm [ __ ] on the
choice of hiring somebody to do a job
that can't accomplish the job regardless
of who they are you know what I mean
but anyway somebody came up to me after
a show on it and the lady was like hey
listen I just want you to know that I
work with disabled people and I
appreciate how you doing these jokes
and that's all I want it because I still
got my point across because what I'm
saying is sometimes the message gets
lost in the delivery well I think I
think if it seems like you're making fun
of the person and not making him the
hero but people are always gonna feel
that way yeah but I mean I did a college
show and the chick was talking about how
she's happy that I'm there because
lesbian and the girl that was there
before was saying so much about the LGBT
and she felt uncomfortable and then I go
and stay and I'm like I don't think
you're gonna like me because I have my
courts to about it but I get on stage
and I do all this stuff into one joke I
did was about my fat friend and that was
the thing that offended her because her
mom used to be fat right right and I was
like well tell that big [ __ ] to
lose weight but it's not it's not about
you really trying to poke fun it's the
situations it's just the situations I
had a friend who was huge lost weight
but did everything like she was still
fat you you would see her like trying to
squeeze in places and you like you lost
not even touching you anymore but she
was she was that person so it's all in
this situation ok simply see how you
just described that as like that's not
mean or like what I what I'm saying is
here's what I'm trying to say I want if
the point I'm trying to get across
ok again here's another example I would
say I don't like being designated driver
because it's like taking care of
autistic kids by the end of the night ok
so all I'm saying is the point of that
joke is that drunk people are are I
don't have you ever been around
autistic kids you know they just they're
all over the place yeah that's the point
it's just an analogy to point a joke but
there are people out there who are like
ok you know you said the way you say the
word autistic and so so what I'm saying
is like here's what's funny about that
though that autistic kid is probably
super brilliant and could do I mean no
I'm saying but if Einstein went out and
you know had eight shots you know I mean
that's freaking hilarious they're
actually really brilliant so there's
nothing really bad about being autistic
can't be social exactly so it's just
like it's just one of these things where
people hear what they want to hear yeah
in my first special my first special I
have this joke about vegans you know I
like my premise of it is the fact that
don't disguise something that I like
with your [ __ ] alright ok don't
disguise it you know I mean like cuz
this ain't you you trying to fool me so
the joke goes it's like I say have you
ever had vegan pizza cuz vegan pizza is
like a transvestite cuz from a distance
you like this
well and then you take a bite and you
like is this dick like so you get the
point I think we should get the hell out
but it's just it's just like so what I'm
saying is in my mind I think you're
gonna get it and my mind I'm just saying
like like a transvestite looks like a
woman and from a distance you're like
damn this chick fine but when you get up
close and Interac you're like oh [ __ ]
you have a dick all right you know
you're not what I thought so that's the
analogy on vegan food it's like it looks
like a hotdog but it's not really meat
that's all I'm trying to say
but anyways I'm ever doing this at a
show and I was preparing for my special
and some lady comes up to me and she's
like you know you you're talking about
you know you're grading the treat you
know and I'm just like you didn't you
hear what I [ __ ] said yeah yeah
pisses me off - in a comedy setting we
are obviously telling a joke right right
so even if you are offended right
obviously my intention is for
entertainment right different from like
if I'm at a presidential debate or I'm
at like a medical talk you know about
something and I make some crass Joe the
transvestite convention that there's a
time and place but like I can't stand it
comedies criticized in a way as if to
say it's just as if like the it's just
like you know what it's like I already
made it this is just a perfect analogy
for comedy
it's like watching white chicks and
going they don't look like women why
would anybody believe that they are
these girl they look nothing like those
people no you have to suspend your
disbelief and just enjoy it
comedies the same way you have to be
like okay this is a comedy environment
alright so let me let me let me let me
let me put the brakes on my sensitivity
because this is the environment for this
but what I'll say to that is a lot of
comedians are pulling back and so
problem is cuz we're getting canceled on
my TV the whole castle culture soon as
you do something wrong you cancel yeah
but but imagine if everybody would have
stuck you know stayed on their path then
you're not you're not really going down
you start going down when everybody goes
I shouldn't say that
oh of course and now everybody is going
watch out even comedians that's why
Damon's not doing stand-up is everybody
sensitive well he's too old school well
kid okay alright I hear what you say so
are is your belief then that you should
be able to say whatever you want no
matter what I think if you do that it
just has to be brilliant okay you have
to race chocolate you got alright but
check us out we just said the same thing
I'm telling you yes cuz being brilliant
means you're being thoughtful that's my
whole point
see you you while you're saying you I
feel like you saying thoughtful it's
like like I feel like you're putting a
bandaid on no no no I I think that being
sought Phileas Fogg
out Amazon and I have a point in the
joke where I say the words handicap
piece of [ __ ] I have to do so much to
get to the point where they know what I
mean why I'm saying it but out of
context like this that sounds like what
how can you ever say that so what I'm
saying is being brilliant being
thoughtful means that you are getting
your point across where people know what
you mean and they don't they're not
misinterpreting it with their [ __ ]
but the problem is you're gonna always
have somebody misinterpret I what's the
ratio you want those what I'm saying
that's what brilliant like me and and
and when I'm like mark and my special
when I do this joke about sorry my
unattractive chicks you can hear the
silence in the room of women shutting
down the problem is women have dealt
with under track
men so it's only cool when it's being
done to you or you're doing it everybody
has somebody that they like or is
attractive and it's not attractive so
for you to be sensitive and think the
whole woman I'm talking about it's like
yeah it's you know what I thought you
know that you know this is like it's
like we're not allowed to have
preference anymore so i pref like like
people [ __ ] on you for your preferences
so that your preference might be like
you want somebody tall like women love
like there's a segment of women they're
like especially tall women if you're
like five eight and up you want to have
a tall dude right so they're
discriminatory towards a little short
dudes talk [ __ ] about it but that's but
my thing is like that's a preference
right like I like I have a joke look I
say like you know you know it's weird
how the double standard between men and
women - because if if I come to some
young girl she's like 28 27 as young for
me and I'm like yo what's up and she
says thank you but I prefer younger and
I'd like guys that are more fit right
that's a preference right and I take
most dudes are like it's cool right now
but if I say to a woman
I prefer younger and more in shape it's
a preference I love asking white guys in
the crowd I'll be like you ever dated a
black woman and some of them are like
you know it's okay it's just a
preference you know your mom was white
and sisters white you know I get it like
so it's like because a white person has
never dated a black woman a white dude
has never dated a bike - doesn't mean he
hates black people no it's just it's
just that's his preference you know boom
you know it's like you know it's like
you go like oh and then we but but you
know I get the idea of like well maybe
you might you know who knows but I don't
know what that is like maybe it's some
kind of maybe there is some deep-rooted
like prejudice that we have in our head
like we don't even realize is there's
like I don't like heels like everybody
asian girl you were able to Latino yes
you know you see like I like I like I
like take care of miss hey like that's a
word that I just made up just coined it
no but I just like their culture which
and then you know his her heart is it
hard for you to date a little bit I'm
like super loving in the beginning and
then come like six months I'm like oh so
you really are like a dude it's it's
really weird I'm more mental but if you
can't you gotta keep stimulating me so
like you even if you just mentioned like
you want to have a threesome
I'm excited again but to have the same
routine so you you you freaky that's
what you just said I'm very freaky very
I I you know it I have this interest in
like the dominatrix world define like
moments this thing I'm like I remember
watching you're out do you you can turn
it on no make sure you turn it on people
are we start singing I don't even
welcome to sexy time with Shante help me
out Griffin
anymore oh my god while I'm out he was
on wildin out I was like a season oh
[ __ ] you use like he was flowing on
Wilin out that whole show became about
flowing yeah weird games that like a
thing in a way is for Christmas you guys
had to improv like you know know if you
want your gift you have to improv know
that my family is funny cuz we got you
know we got the Jehovah's Witnesses who
still got gifts better gifts before or
after Christmas you guys but not on the
day oh you guys were jolly and then you
gave me a gift card some of them are my
grandpa really ah didn't give it okay my
grandpa oh he got uh epilepsy and still
knocking on doors Wow like that's scary
see that's a funny premise please you
got to talk about that on stage did your
grandpa got epilepsy epileptic seizure
no you know if I saw him coming I'd be
flicking my lights what's the thing that
they forget oh he's got dementia yeah
yeah oh so you like epilepsy epilepsy
later forgetting that you've knocking on
doors all day our doors he like hello he
like uh you knocked on my door
no I didn't is my door yeah my mom I'm
dealing with that with my mom right now
is it is it uh do you laugh oh I talk
about it on stage it's hilarious oh man
my mom's funny is [ __ ] with it like it's
it's like she thinks her grandma's alive
you know so you know so I'm like I think
grandma live five minutes away you know
so she wants to walk you know to me and
I'm trying to tell her like my you can't
you know and they
she'll be like you know I showed her on
the map I said look mom this is our
place where you are right now
let me put grandma's address in in
Belize grandma's houses in Belize okay
when it was there 35 years ago okay
so then she sees the line go down
through California down through Mexico
across to Belize you know to me and
she's she goes she goes she's my mom
laughs Erik grandma's house is five
minutes away I didn't walk through
Mexico you know but then when I first
did it she was like this hot first
shoulder I was like okay mom here's a
very Moss house okay so see Google Maps
it takes two days to drive to Grandma's
house but you said you walked so let's
change it to walk three years it takes
39 days to walk please yes it's not bad
right we we started today and she was
like this she just laughed about it cuz
she thinks I'm crazy that's the thing
about it that's the weirdest thing about
is that she thinks I'm crazy but she
remembers you oh yeah yeah she's not at
that point but she's just like has these
weird quirks like she says like one you
know at first when it was starting to
happen it was like you know she was like
I just got back from this trip I said
I'm like you didn't go on a trip this
she goes like this okay Erik I didn't go
right did this [ __ ] go on a trip I'm
just like it's so it's like it's a weird
thing to deal with it it's kind of funny
but it's just the way I deal with it
some people are like remember you yeah
it doesn't matter but who knows the day
could come look my best friend she her
mother has that man I experienced it
last year when I was in New York I went
to her house and my best friend went to
work I saw it's me upstairs and so I'm
going downstairs and she's like you want
me to come with you
and I'm like night like you know I'm
about to go walk to Target she's like oh
come so anyway she's trying
figure out the time that she has to pick
up the best friends kids right the long
story short I wind up not going to
target because she just kept going back
to like coming back you know kind of
thing you just go yeah so we get back
and then she goes are you hungry she
cook oxtail Jamaican she cook meals for
me so I go yeah I'm hungry I'm gonna
take a shower and then I'm gonna come
downstairs and you know coming she's
like okay I'm in the shower and she
comes in with like she has the plate
already made and I'm like I'm not like
come on ready yet but she wanted me to
eat she's like come eat so to me I don't
know I think it's brilliant I think the
fact that she remembers a daughter and
her great yeah it is won't mean I guess
a it is what it is you know so yeah it's
not something you can like like you just
had to have this is it this is what she
has there's no sense being all super
upset about it I just come a monster the
weird thing is like dementia how it
affects the brain but like she's still
sarcastic right
prideful you don't I mean that she still
gotta says him it's like the fact cuz
she's prideful even about this dementia
cuz like the thing about grandma's house
this is the fights we get in you know
she's like let's go in the car I'm gonna
show you alright so we in the car
driving around for 45 minutes like okay
where's that ma where and then she's
like if I could just find the river you
know I'm showing her to GP it's just
like it's so like but the fact that you
wouldn't did that for your mom is
amazing here's a different take on it
though huh the fact how dope is it to be
able to forget this stuff you don't want
to remember I agree
I see I started to think about it like
you know what how great is it that you
think this person that you had this
memory for is still alive grant right
cuz my mom was like she still sometimes
she'll even be like this she'll be like
she thinks she lives at her grandma's
house so she even say aircraft to
retirement place but we're gonna go home
soon I like mom you at home right Eric I
I live it you know
then once all your stuff doing in the
closet you know there's like there's no
way to reason with them so you just have
to go so I'm finding other techniques
when she wants to go out walk to
Grandma's house I say grandma ain't
worried she not feeling well today
you just distract them music thing like
that but I don't know I've been talking
about it a lot because that's how I deal
with it you know cuz let's so people are
not hitting me up like you know but just
like cuz people also have techniques oh
dude I do this and you do you know do
that so it's just like finding a way to
you know just deal with it because what
it really is is it's about how it makes
us uncomfortable right and so you know
we have to deal with this like okay I'm
a lion am I like what do I say yeah you
got a lie the scary part too is like my
biggest thing would be them going out
into the world by themselves s what but
see that's why we're here we had to move
my mom and my stepdad had to move back
from Spain they were living his pain for
four years and by the way she still
thinks she's insane she on Facebook
talked about I love living in Spain you
know I see on Facebook don't get me
started
you don't understand I hope she she
might even watched his I hope not
she don't even watch my stuff but like
you know what I do you know what I did I
had to go into her Facebook page and
made all her post private she don't even
know because my mom's also racist on
Facebook she just like say mom wait no
my mom she's yeah just like what I did
inside all that so like she's like
saying things like oh you can't say that
on Facebook and she was like whatever I
want you know I said you know mom I'm on
TV so you know so what I did was I
blocked like she don't even know so she
just type and stuff and she don't even
know that her posts aren't going public
that's what I had to do I got this is
one more work the whole thing out it's
funny you say they're so dumb
it's fun something I'm working on right
now with my wife my my writing buddy I
said this is it
cuz you know you're going all these
meetings for these like sitcoms and
shows and they're always like we need to
do something personal for you you know
and you don't know what that is and so
like I got something so we'll see what
this I mean not to tag on to anything
but i'ma just say the fact that you are
in a position where you are in your
career and having to move your mom in to
take care of dementia I know yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's crazy a lot you know so
but anyways you know it's like that's
just two things we had to deal with and
it's like but that made me start working
on my health because like I'm single guy
again you know just got out of
relationship not it can be if it's young
I get like like like if somebody's like
50 or 60 and they get dementia
Alzheimer's and it could be a genetic
thing but like I don't know so that's
why I'm all like okay I got to get my
cholesterol in because it's so you look
at all the things that cause dementia
inflammation and all this is I'm doing a
cryo I'm taking 90 supplements I'm
cutting back on what I eat I'm trying to
get I'm trying to lose weight sound like
I started really thinking about my
health or at 30 years I'm gonna be like
you know I'm still recording it like it
is on my Netflix special
[Laughter]
dementia podcast but it's not about
dementia people if your parent or
somebody your family has dementia bring
them on my podcast and I just interview
them so people don't know like how be
know what the and all serious know
seriousness like one of the things that
got to me was when we took her to the
doctor and they had these mental tests
that they have to do like draw a clock
and make it 11:10 know that it was draw
a clock and make the time eleven past
ten past eleven right
so my mom drew the clock right she had
to do it twice because I saw her she was
bucking it out like Oh hot the numbers
are too close so then she drew all the
numbers and then she wrote 11 10 Eggman
you know I thought myself
oh that's she wrote it she made a
digital but in a circle in my mind I was
like was she you said no but then he but
but what I'm saying those as I was
watching her try to do these mental
exercises I saw that's where I actually
saw the effects of what it is because
their personality things flow so easily
did you want this person to be the same
right but they it's like these little
weird quirks you never mean I got a
relative who's a schizophrenic and you
know sometimes I think she's faking but
and I say that because she'll say
something super crazy and laughs and I'm
like mmm but I remember being young and
her being around me and she would like
talk about how the moon was following
her and stuff like that and so I would I
was always that kid that because if you
actually look at the mode the moon is
moving with you it might be following
you know it's like so big anyway it
doesn't matter it's just like it
literally looked like it was moving with
you but I just I realize me giving her
some validation about what she sees in
life it helps her yes so then she wants
me around so hard for me because they
have to pull my hat while my mom is that
I'm like I find myself being like my
you're you're in California yeah you
know and then you you can see the
frustration though you know to Spain
with yeah I know be it like you should
go where wherever you're gonna meet her
you should dress the whole apartment or
the house no this is how you get through
life see my problem is I'm too much of a
comedian and God could be an [ __ ] so
when like when she's first talking about
her grandma I was like oh
like I was like what you know grandma if
she was alive she'd be a hundred forty
years old you know yeah my mom's like my
mom's like what's she doing good you
know that's what my mom say she doing
get it like it just stubborn and so then
my [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm like well then we
should call Guinness okay because you
know apparently we got the oldest woman
in the world a family so just turned
into that kind of [ __ ] so I would prop
up a hundred and forty year old like my
version of what that would look like oh
I gotta go but you know what's crazy
like the other day I said I tried my
thing I said grandma I heard from
grandma she's not feeling well
I said grandma's not feeling well today
and my mom on that is how do you know
all right
that's like what do you mean I was like
your brother called me you know because
I was like why is she trying to
investigate not even that I think she's
trying I think it's part of her brain
did like in that moment I thought maybe
she was starting to realize oh I don't
think but then if I'm confirming that
grandma actually is alive right am i
helping or hurting I don't know what to
do what I hate to break this down like
what if the whole thing was her not
being able to tell you that grandma's
dead because now you believe you guys
thanks for watching and listen man I
hope thanks for coming on thank you as
you've got things going on I want you to
come back on I'll have all your
information below you can see all our
information this is a lovely and
talented miss Shante Williams the dark
you know and you are the best look I'm
glad you came on and everybody make sure
you thanks for subscribing make sure you
hit the subscribe and like button and
share and I appreciate the love even the
haters I see your comments sometimes you
know you guys are great I appreciate all
the love and support and thank you for
watching good for what Griffon and I'll
see you next week
[Music]